HE TWEETED THIS, "96-0 IN THE
UNITED STATES SENATE.
CONGRATULATIONS, AMERICA!"
THAT’S RIGHT, HE WAS UNANIMOUS
PER THE PRESIDENT LETTING US OF
THE VOTE COUNT.
KELLYANNE CONWAY, COUNSELOR TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP, JOINS ME IN HER
LIFE.
BOY, THERE’S A LOT OF NEWS TO
GET TO TODAY.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS RIGHT IN THE
MIDDLE OF IT.
LET’S START WITH WHERE WE ARE IN
THE STIMULUS BILL, AND KIND OF
WHERE YOU THINK IT NEEDS SHORING
UP.
SEEING THOSE ON EMPLOYMENT
NUMBERS NOW, MAYBE WE WILL NEED
MORE.
>> HARRIS, THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
I JUST LEFT A CALL THAT THE
PRESIDENT AND VICE PRESIDENT ARE
HAVING WITH OUR NATION’S
GOVERNORS.
I CAME OFF I CALLED TO COME
HERE.
I WILL TELL YOU, AND THAT CALL,
SECRETARY MNUCHIN REPORTED TO
THE GOVERNMENT IS PRECISELY
WITHIN THE STAMOS PACKAGE FOR
THEM.
AND HE REVIEWED THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE OVER $100 BILLION IN DIRECT
SUPPORT TO OUR HOSPITALS, OUR
FIRST RESPONDERS, OUR
HEALTH CARE WORKERS.
IN ADDITION, MONEY FOR
LIFE-SAVING VACCINES AND
REFUNDING OUR CRITICAL SUPPLY
CHAIN.
HE ALSO TALKED ABOUT THE
$370 BILLION PLUS FOR A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS.
I WANT TO READ IT TO YOU, IT’S
PRETTY IMPRESSIVE TO HEAR.
TWO MONTHS’ WORTH OF YOUR
EMPLOYEES SALARIES, SO LONG AS
YOU KEEP THOSE EMPLOYEES.
YOU CAN’T JUST KICK THEM OFF THE
PAYROLL AND FIRE THEM AND USE
THE MONEY FOR OTHER PURPOSES.
THERE ARE GUARANTEES AND THEY
ARE.
IT’S ALSO MEANT TO HELP WITH
CHILD CARE NEEDS OF THOSE
HEALTH CARE WORKERS,
FIRST RESPONDERS, SANITATION
WORKERS, WHO CAN’T NOT SHOW UP
TO WORK.
WHO CAN’T TELEWORK, HARRIS.
WE NEED THEM ON THE FRONT LINES,
AND GOD BLESS EACH AND EVERY ONE
OF THEM.
WE WANT TO HELP THEM WITH
CHILD CARE NEEDS, AS WELL.
>> Harris: AMEN.
>> TODAY ARE TOUGH AND IMPLEMENT
NUMBERS.
THESE ARE SHOCKING BUT NOT
SURPRISING.
ANYBODY DOMINIC EVERYBODY WARNED
US IT WOULD BE THIS BAD.
EXTERNALLY UNPRECEDENTED TIMES
YIELD UNPRECEDENTED NUMBERS LIKE
THIS.
IT ALSO YIELDS PRESIDENT AND
MEASURES LIKE THIS STIMULUS.
>> Harris: KELLYANNE, I WANT
THE AUDIENCE -- FORGIVE ME, I
KNOW THERE’S A LITTLE BIT OF
DELAY.
BUT WE WORKED TOGETHER ON THIS.
WHAT IS ON THE SCREEN FOR OUR
VIEWERS RIGHT NOW, WE ARE GOING
TO HIT THAT NUMBER SO PEOPLE CAN
SEE WHAT IT IS.
THE JOBLESS CLAIMS, WE’VE HIT A
RECORD, 3.2
$8 MILLION,
UP FROM 282,000 THE PREVIOUS
WEEK.
OF COURSE, WE’VE BEEN IN RECORD
TERRITORY ON HOW LOW IT’S BEEN
RECENTLY, SO THAT IS A CHANGE.
I JUST WANT TO JUMP IN THERE AND
SAY THIS, IT ALSO SHATTERED THE
GREAT RECESSION OF 2008.
THE ALL-TIME HIGH PEAK OF
695,000 IN A WEEK, SET BACK IN
OCTOBER OF ’82.
I UNDERSTAND THE AMOUNT THAT’S
IN THERE NOW.
SOME GOVERNORS ARE SAYING IN
THEIR STATES, THE MONEY FROM
THEM WON’T BE ENOUGH.
BUT WHEN YOU SEE THOSE NUMBERS,
YOU WANT PEOPLE TO KEEP PEOPLE
ON THE PAYROLL, THIS MAY NOT BE
ENOUGH.
IS THERE A FEE 4 COMING?
>> THEY VERY WELL COULD BE.
ACTUALLY, THE PRESIDENT JUST
BROACHED THAT IN RESPONSE TO A
VERY SPECIFIC QUESTION HE GOT
FROM ONE OF THE STATE LEADERS.
I’M SURE THE WHITE HOUSE WILL
PUT OUT A READ OUT.
THIS IS THE THIRD OF THREE IN
VERY QUICK SUCCESSION PACKAGES
COMING OUT IN A BICAMERAL,
BIPARTISAN WAY.
IF THIS REACHES THE PRESIDENT’S
DESK TOMORROW, HARRIS, AS WE
EXPECT IT WILL, HE WILL SIGN IT
AND THE IMPLANTATION BEGINS.
SECRETARY MNUCHIN SAID WITHIN
THE NEXT TWO WEEKS PEOPLE CAN
SEE THE DIRECT DEPOSIT OR CHECKS
IF YOU DON’T HAVE DIRECT
DEPOSIT.
$1200 PER PERSON FOR A FAMILY OF
FOUR, WITH TWO SCHOOL-AGE CHILDR
$3400.
WE RECOGNIZE AS THIS GOES ON IT
MIGHT NOT BE ENOUGH, BUT WE
STAND READY TO CONTINUE GIVING
THAT RELIEF TO AMERICAN WORKERS,
INDIVIDUALS AND INDUSTRIES THAT
ARE IN SPECIFIC DISTRESS.
LET ME TELL YOU, THIS IS JUST A
CONTINUATION OF THE PRO-AMERICAN
WORKER AGENDA THAT THE PRESIDENT
HAS PUT FORWARD FROM THE
BEGINNING.
WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE KNOW, THIS IS A
MEDICAL CRISIS, NOT A FINANCIAL
CRISIS, FIRST AND FOREMOST.
WHICH IS BY THE PRESIDENT SAYS,
"WE ARE GOING TO TURN BACK ON
THE AMERICAN ECONOMY, BUT OFTEN
WE FOLLOW THE FACTS IN THE
DATA."
HARRIS, WENT TO QUICKLY MENTION
A FEW OF THE PLACES -- I’M
SORRY, THERE MUST BE A DELAY,
SORRY.
>> Harris: I WANT TO SEGUE
FROM WHAT YOU SAID.
YOU SET THIS UP PERFECTLY.
HE SAID
THIS IS A MEDICAL EMERGENCY.
BOY, I’VE GOT TO TELL YOU,
KELLYANNE, IT’S LOOKING PRETTY
DIRE IN SOME PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY.
NOT EVERY PART.
HOSPITALS ACROSS AMERICA ARE
FACING A CRISIS WITH SHORTAGES
OF EQUIPMENT AND PROTECTIVE
GEAR.
WE ARE HEARING DIRECTLY FROM THE
PEOPLE ON THE FRONT LINES, SO NO
POLITICS HERE.
WE ARE TALKING WITH THOSE PEOPLE
AT THE HOSPITALS.
13 PATIENTS AT A NEW YORK CITY
HOSPITAL HAVE DIED OF
CORONAVIRUS.
AT ONE HOSPITAL, KELLYANNE, IN
ONE DAY.
AND ALL OF THE CITY’S 180000
INTENSIVE CARE BEDS REPORTEDLY
EXPECTED TO BE FULL BY TOMORROW,
BY FRIDAY, HEADED INTO THE
WEEKEND.
WE HAD A DOCTOR ON LAST HOUR,
DR. MAKARY, ON "OUTNUMBERED,"
KELLYANNE, WHO SAID THEY ARE
SPLITTING VENTILATORS.
I’M GOING TO DRILL DOWN WITH
DOCTORS LATER THIS HOUR TO SEE
THAT WHAT THAT MEANS, AND
WHETHER THEY CAN BE REPURPOSED,
AND WHAT THAT DOES WITH SUCH
HIGH CONTAGIONS.
BUT ALL OF THIS SPEAKS TO WHAT
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT.
THIS IS A MEDICAL EMERGENCY.
HOW DOES THE PRESIDENT MEETS
THAT AND ALSO FACED THE HEADWIND
OF WHAT’S COMING IN THE ECONOMY?
>> WE’VE BEEN WORKING AROUND THE
CLOCK.
WHEN I SAY "WE," BEGINNING WITH
THE PRESIDENT AND
VICE PRESIDENT, THE TASK FORCE,
OBVIOUSLY FEMA IS VERY HEAVILY
INVOLVED NOW RUNNING THE
RESPONSE, AS FEMA DOES.
I JUST HEARD ADMINISTRATOR PETE
GAYNOR TELL THE NATION’S
GOVERNORS AND MAYORS AND
TERRITORY AND TRIBAL LEADERS
THAT FEMA IS THERE, BUT FIRST
YOUR LOCAL COUNTIES AND CITIES
HAVE TO GO TO THE STATE.
BECAUSE WE ARE DEALING WITH THE
STATE.
THEN YOU GO TO YOU OR TEN FEMA
REGIONAL ADMINISTRATORS ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
THEY ARE SURGING SUPPLIES.
IN FACT, HE MADE CLEAR WE ARE
ACQUIRING SUPPLIES OVERSEAS, WE
ARE ACQUIRING SUPPLIES FROM
STATE TO STATE, AND THAT WE DO
WANT OUR ANESTHESIOLOGISTS, OUR
CRITICAL CARE MEDICINE, OUR
CLINICS, IF HE WENT TO TAKE
ACCOUNT OF MAYBE WHAT THEY DO
HAVE SO WE CAN HAVE A BETTER
PIECE OF INFORMATION, BETTER
DATA ABOUT WHAT EXISTS.
IN THE LAST TWO DAYS ALONE, 4400
VENTILATORS HAVE BEEN SENT BY
FEMA TO THE STATE OF NEW YORK.
WE KNOW THAT THE GOVERNOR THERE
SAID HE NEEDS MORE AND MORE, AS
DO OTHER STATES.
WE ARE TRYING TO GO TO THE
PLACES MOST IN NEED WHERE WE SEE
THOSE CLUSTERS THAT ARE THERE
AND GROWING.
I DO THINK IT’S VERY
DISAPPOINTING THAT THE MAYOR OF
NEW YORK CITY HIMSELF WAS RIDING
THE SUBWAY ON MARCH 5TH AND
TELLING PEOPLE TO GO OUT ON THE
TOWN --
>> Harris: KELLYANNE, I’M
GOING TO STOP YOU ON THE
POLITICS.
>> IT’S NOT POLITICS, WE HAVE A
VERY DIRE SITUATION IN
NEW YORK CITY.
THAT’S NOT POLITICS.
>> Harris: WE DO HAVE A DIRE
SITUATION.
WE DO HAVE A DIRE SITUATION, AND
I --
>> LOOK, I THINK THIS
UNANIMOUSLY PASSED IN THE SENATE
IS THE POINT.
IT’S BIPARTISAN, FRANKLY IT’S
NONPARTISAN, HARRIS.
WE HAVEN’T TALKED ABOUT POLITICS
HERE IN A VERY LONG TIME AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THIS IS NONPARTISAN, PEOPLE ARE
SUFFERING.
WHICH IS WHY THIS IS THE THIRD
OF THREE ECONOMIC RELIEF
PACKAGES THAT THIS PRESIDENT IS
SIGNING TO GIVE THAT DIRECT
RELIEF.
I’M VERY HAPPY THAT THE CONGRESS
AND THE SENATE HAVE COME
TOGETHER IN A BIPARTISAN,
BICAMERAL WAY, TO DO WHAT?
IN ADDITION TO EVERYTHING ELSE,
OVER $100 BILLION IN DIRECT
RELIEF TO THOSE POSS
POODLES.
THEY ARE THE HEROES, THERE OUT
ON THE FRONT LINES AND THEY
CAN’T DELIVER, THEY CAN’T TAKE A
DAY OFF.
>> Harris: 100%.
>> WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY’VE
GOT THE PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT.
I WAS HAPPY TO SEE -- MORE
RELIEVED -- TO SEE THE GOVERNOR
OF NEW YORK SAY IN HIS PRESS
CONFERENCE THAT THEY HAVE PPE,
IMMEDIATE NEEDS, THEY HAVE IT
FOR THE IMMEDIATE TERM.
AGAIN, WE TAKE THOSE INVENTORIES
AND SURGE OUR SUPPLIES.
WE ARE WORKING OVERTIME TO DO
THAT.
>> Harris: REAL QUICKLY, IS
THERE DISCUSSION IN THE
WHITE HOUSE TODAY WITH THE
PRESIDENT ABOUT THAT EASTER DATE
AS WE NOW -- DOCTORS ARE SAYING
-- WE HAVEN’T HIT THE APEX HE
HAD IN SOME OF THESE HARD AREAS
BY COVID-19.
KELLYANNE, I KNOW YOU LIVED ON
THE EAST COAST UP BY ME IN
JERSEY.
PEOPLE HAVE LEFT NEW YORK CITY.
THEY HAVE LEFT AND FANNED OUT,
WHICH MEANS THEY ARE POTENTIALLY
TAKING IT WITH THEM.
SO WHICH SECTORS DO YOU OPEN?
I’M CURIOUS ABOUT THAT DATE, AND
THEN I’LL LET YOU GO.
>> SURE, LET ME SAY A FEW
THINGS.
FIRST OF ALL, THIS IS BY THE
WHITE HOUSE, AND
DR. DEBBIE BIRX, WHO IS QUART
NEEDING THE RESPONSE HERE FOR
THE WHITE HOUSE, THIS IS WHY,
HARRIS, SHE SAID THAT IF YOU
WERE IN NEW YORK IN THE LAST 14
DAYS AND HE LEFT THERE, YOU
SHOULD SELF-QUARANTINE OR SELF
ISOLATE, WHATEVER MEDICAL TERM
WAS.
SHE IS SAYING THAT THE PEOPLE
OUT IN THEIR HOUSE IN THE
HAMPTONS, UP IN CONNECTICUT,
DOWN IN FLORIDA, WHEREVER YOU’VE
GONE THAT YOU MIGHT NOT
BE A CARRIER AND NOT KNOW IT.
SHE WAS ON TOP OF THAT
IMMEDIATELY.
TO ANSWER YOUR OTHER QUESTION,
THIS IS WHY I MENTIONED
NEW YORK CITY.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE A LOT OF
COMMUTERS FROM BERGEN,
ESSEX COUNTY, NEW JERSEY,
CONNECTICUT, PENNSYLVANIA, WHO
ARE GOING AND OUT OF
NEW YORK CITY.
BEFORE THEY WENT ON VIRTUAL
LOCKDOWN, HE DIDN’T KNOW THIS.
THAT IS WHY IT WAS UNFORTUNATE
THAT THERE WERE MIXED MESSAGES
THERE WHILE THE PLACES LIKE
CALIFORNIA WERE LOCKING DOWN.
>> Harris: THAT’S A GOOD
POINT.
>> NO, IT’S TRUE.
YOU DO SEE, I HEARD
GOVERNOR MURPHY OF NEW JERSEY
SAY IT ON THE GOVERNOR’S CALL,
AND NEW JERSEY AS OF TODAY AS AN
EMERGENCY DISASTER IN PLACE.
I THINK THAT’S THE NINTH STATE,
HARRIS.
NEW JERSEY IS RELEASING A SURGE
IN CASES OVERNIGHT, OVER 50% OR
60%, AS I UNDERSTAND.
A LOT OF THOSE COMMUTERS IN AND
OUT OF MANHATTAN.
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION ABOUT
EASTER, THE PRESIDENT IS TELLING
THE AMERICANS -- A GREAT
AMERICAN COMEBACK.
HE USED EASTER AS AN EXAMPLE.
BUT THEN HE CAME BACK IN THE
PRESS CONFERENCE AND SAID,
"LISTEN, THIS IS A MEDICAL
CRIS, NOT A FINANCIAL CRISIS."
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE
KNOW THIS WON’T LAST FOREVER.
WE WILL FOLLOW THE SCIENCE AND
DATA."
>> Harris: HE SOUNDS FIT DOWN
MY CLICKABLE.
>> HE SAID HE WILL FOLLOW THE
DATA AND
THE FACTS.
DR. BIRX, DR. FAUCI, THEY ARE
HERE DOING A GREAT JOB.
THE ECONOMIC RELIEF IS THERE
TODAY FOR PEOPLE, THAT THEY SEE
THE GOVERNMENT IS HELPING THEM.
>> Harris: ALL RIGHT.
KELLYANNE, THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND THANKS
FOR GETTING INTO THE
NITTY-GRITTY.